ثمه تساؤلات كبيره عن الاسباب الاقتصاديه
والماليه التي دفعت بنك السيليكون فاليلا
لانهيار سريعا وبشكل لم يسبق له مثيل منذ
الازمه الماليه العالميه قبل 15 عاما
فالمصرف كان يصنف في المركز السادس عشر من
حيث الحجم في الولايات المتحده بقيمه وصول
تتجاوز 200 مليار دولار وكانت له فروع في
كندا والصين والدنمارك والمانيا والهند
واسرائيل والسويد وفي نهايه العام الماضي
بلغت قيمه وصوله 209 مليارات دولار بينما
تجاوزت ودائعه 175 مليارا فما الذي دفعه
الى هذا الانهيار يكشف تقرير لمجله
ايكونوميسرو بريطانيه اسباب انهيار البنك
وذلك جراء عوامل عده فقد تضاعفت ودائع هذا
البنك باكثر من اربع مرات خلال اربع سنوات
وذلك من 44 مليار دولار في عام 2017 الى
189 بليارا في نهايه عام 2020 وخلال تلك
السنوات ارتفع حجم قروض البنك لشركات
التكنولوجيا الناشئه من 23 مليار دولار
الى 66 مليارا ونظرا لان البنوك تجني
الارباح من الفارق بين سعر الفائده الذي
تدفعه على الودائع والسعر الذي يدفعه
المقترضون فان وجود قاعده ودائعه اكبر
بكثير من القرود تسبب في مشكله عميقه لهذا
البنك اما حل هذه المشكله فكان يتطلب
حصوله على اصول اخرى كي يجني منها فائده
وهو امر دفعه في نهايه عام 2021 لاستثمار
1828 مليار دولار معظمها في سندات الرهن
العقاري وسندات الخزانه باسعار مرتفعه لكن
جاءت رياح التحول في السياسه النقديه
الامريكيه بتبني رفع اسعار الفائده لكبح
جماح التضخم لتتراجع ارباح بنك سيليكون
فالي فقد انخفضت اسعار السندات على نحو
ترك البنك مكشوفا ماليا بشكل خطير وهو ما
دفع العملاء الى سحب نسبه كبيره من
ودائعهم هذا الامر واجبر البنك على بيع
محفظته من السندات بالكامل باسعار اقل مما
كانت عليه متكبدا بذلك خسائر بنحو ملياري
دولار وتسبب هذا الامر في فجوه ماليه حاول
ان يسدها بزياده راس المال لكنه فشل ليصبح
انهياره امرا حتميا